it's going to take three episodes for
everybody to be appointment viewing with
Game of Thrones so some people are going
to stream the first one like a couple
days after like you guys did second one
even more people are going to be on it
third one I think most are gonna be
watching it by that fourth episode did
you see this picture or this video on
Instagram amazing it's the guy filming
an apartment building from the ground
all the win all the lights are flashing
inside the apartments all the same time
all watching Game of Thrones fire it's
unbelievable crazy appointment
television back I think by episode four
that 10 million number you were seeing
yeah which was like total watch live and
streamed and all that other [ __ ] I think
you're seeing that that's a little
tricky because I think if it stays good
oh no no no yeah yeah but I'm also uh
gonna disagree with myself is because
people on the west coast they might
still watch it at nine their time nah
I love that I love going on Twitter and
seeing people see things yeah they don't
want to see all the spoilers and [ __ ]
like that so yeah I think I I'm just
stoked and I think we need to be so
[ __ ] great grateful I know I'm I'm
like dick riding but I want a dick ride
right now the expectation for that show
to be good was was so high I mean it's
following one of the greatest shows ever
I know the last few seasons didn't live
up to our expectations but it was still
we all agree one of the greatest shows
ever right so we're comparing it to the
entirety of one of the greatest shows
ever
and that episode that first episode was
built to fail
and the fact that there isn't even that
much criticism about it means that it
was a massive success who was doing this
one
but they have what's his face involved
in this George George is still involved
yeah okay so different show Runners
George still involved
and I just thought that they [ __ ]
killed it man like they did it was
amazing what did you guys think like I
know Akash hasn't hasn't seen it but I
think everybody else here has seen it
ball have you seen it yeah okay I did
fall asleep last 10 minutes but I
thought it was like my only issue is I
thought it was kind of save it
save it to when you finish the show like
go out
I fell asleep I was so tired why did you
say the show sucked unbelief
14 Wikipedia Pages until seven in the
morning
you can't watch one of the greatest
shows that's ever happened to go I
absolutely I absolutely loved it because
it didn't feel like they were just
trying to copy the previous [ __ ] they're
like hey we're gonna even start it
different where it's like we're just
gonna give you words and
um catch you up to speed so the time in
which this is about to take place like I
love that it's like yo we're gonna do
[ __ ] different and
uh it doesn't feel like they're just
trying to copy all the characters from
lasting I was a little concerned about I
think that's would have been the easier
way to go it's like hey
Aria making it so far it doesn't feel
that way yeah there's some similarities
but it doesn't feel like it's like just
straight I don't see what's a little imp
[ __ ]
I'm sorry I watched that I watched eight
seasons of that [ __ ] I still don't know
names this one is gonna take me three
seasons before I know like one I don't
know anything yeah but like I haven't I
didn't see that character and everybody
loved that character I would have think
they would have tried to recreate him
from the get-go I did not think HBO
would do that just because it's HBO so
they know yeah but the pressure for them
I'm just kind of sipping on them why you
want it yeah he wants it man
piece of [ __ ]
I fell asleep fell asleep last [ __ ]
10 minutes I told us right before we
started yeah everybody's seen it let you
get let you get bullied by everybody
okay that's why
everybody was safe after he was like yes
I'm good because he couldn't have been
like it sucked I didn't even make it
through I fell asleep yeah
it didn't suck
um okay
their budget was [ __ ] they had to cut
the Batgirl that he's been like however
many 50 million dollars on whatever the
[ __ ] 90. they were cutting 90. they're
cutting mad programming HBO fives huh
they also HBO is dead
ah no no what they did is they cut HBO
Max shows specifically HBO Max show okay
so I think that they are producing a lot
of content for HBO Max but I think
that's all that it is now I think
there's an interest into one and then I
think they were purchased by I think
Discovery yeah so no [ __ ] yeah but uh I
know that sounds weird because we're
like Discovery was like the tiny little
Channel but I think Discovery is part of
a bigger Thing by something glamorous
it's always funny how that works no no
no but they will though but what I
appreciate about HBO is they will cut
they cut a pilot episode that they put
crazy money in for a Game of Thrones
spin-off yo Batgirl was trash bro yeah
like this little bat [ __ ] on Instagram
crying about it you know your movie
doo-doo is trash because HBO only puts
out the godliest [ __ ]
female lead shows big little lies every
Show's female lead uh the woman Nicole
Kim and the other one the undoing or
whatever that was her as the main
character female lead show female driven
they don't have a problem with that Z
there's nothing to do with female driven
they wanted that they're dying for it it
was a black female driven show yeah oh
it's like it wasn't Batgirl she wasn't
Batgirl but she had like superpowers no
it's that girl literally that they have
another show it's a black guy look at me
earlier and you don't know dog [ __ ]
about dog [ __ ] all right guys we're
gonna take a break from this exclusive
patreon clip because I gotta tell you
all about Incognito Okay thousands of
companies are collecting aggregating and
trading your personal data without you
knowing anything about it and that's
messed up okay you got the right to
request data Brokers to delete what
information they have about you and
protect your privacy the bad news is it
would take you years to do it manually
literally years but the good thing is
incognit can do that messy work for you
automatically incognate helps you
protect your privacy and take your
personal data off the market by reaching
out to data Brokers on your behalf
requesting your personal data removal
and dealing with their objections think
about the things that are up on the
Internet of you yes your full name email
home address shopping habits your social
security number could be up there on the
internet okay you subscribe to a free
newsletter shortly after you're
receiving all the spam from unknown
senders right you don't have to have
that happen Incognito can wipe your data
from the internet so these people that
are getting you to sign up for these
free newsletters can't share or even
sell your data to all these other people
I mean it's not only them maybe someone
found out your home address phone number
and personal information about you and
your relatives you could have all that
stuff wiped from the internet so it's
not shared by everybody and right now
the first 100 people to use the code
Schultz Schulz at the link below we're
gonna get 20 off in cogni protect your
privacy today go to incogni.com Schultz
that's s-c-h-u-l-z use the code Schultz
Schulz to take your personal data off
the market now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon clip join the [ __ ]
Army right now at patreon.com flake all
right so back to back to the Game of
Thrones episode one I'm so impressed
with the execution execution is the
hardest thing in the world like
everybody got ideas fewer people got
really good ideas and fewer people can
execute them and they execute the [ __ ]
out of that [ __ ] like that was
yeah that that was excellent like all
the actors are are interesting like the
I'm I'm still waiting for who the who
the person is I really want to follow we
were talking about this a little bit the
other day which is like like for example
season two of Game of Thrones I was
fascinated by Tyrion season one I think
it was obviously yeah and it's like but
season two I'm like yo Tyrion whatever
he says is brilliant however he acts as
brilliant every scene was brilliant yes
that is has that like so I'm still
waiting for who that person is here I'll
tell you one thing that they did in
season or in the first episode that I
absolutely [ __ ] loved
or two things
there's the the hand to the king the
character Otto Hightower Otto high tower
Otto
what the [ __ ] is that oh no I tell you a
black mechanic
Auto Hightower so Otto so you think that
this guy's kind of like a a good guy
nerd maybe like sweet he's kind of
looking out for the king
and after the king loses his wife and
his daughter and his son to be
he sends his daughter comes to his room
his daughter's like helping out the
princess his daughter comes to his room
and he basically sends his daughter to
go [ __ ] the king pimp that [ __ ] and he
goes put on something nice like
something your mother would have wore
so it goes from this very innocent
character who thinks like a good sweet
hand
to someone who's like willing to
potentially manipulate the king and
using his own daughter's [ __ ] to do it
and up until that point the episode
didn't have like real Game of Thrones
teeth remember Game of Thrones would
kill off a character you loved you have
a kid off of top of a castle in the
first episode yeah and make every and
like [ __ ] with your emotions with
characters like they made Jaime the most
hateable person and all of a sudden you
started liking Jamie and in like every
single [ __ ] episode you were like
what are you doing to me man yeah and
that made me feel like okay you still
got it you're willing to make me hate
someone that I potentially like so there
was that scene that I [ __ ] love and I
was like okay it's gonna be roller
coaster the other scene I thought was
great was
the Damon character yeah goes in which
one's name the the wrong dude the
brothers
right yeah
he goes in
and he goes
he's basically going he's speaking to
his I guess uncle or who is viserys to
him brother oh that's his brother yeah
brother so he's speaking his brother and
he basically goes you're weak and all
these people around you are leeches
right
and in that and then his brother
banishes him in that moment you're like
ah this guy's a [ __ ] hot head he
can't do [ __ ] in a moment he was the
most trustworthy [ __ ] bro and
then what happens that guy
Otto Hightower sends his daughter to go
[ __ ] the king but it's also Damon's
fault that Otto Hightower did Damon
fought made fun of his dead wife at the
council meeting and no one did anything
viserys didn't do anything he said you
know he likes to egg you on why do you
let him do that then he Damon fought
Otto hightower's son and threw the Lance
at the ground and tossed his kid off the
thing yeah and then Damon asked for
Allison his daughter's favor to win the
whole thing so it's like he didn't do it
directly but Damon also was [ __ ] with
Otto Hightower the whole time and
viserys wasn't really doing anything to
like stop him so Otto is like oh you
don't have my best interest in me like
you're not you're not protecting me from
your derelict brother
right okay I see what you're saying with
that okay but but but this scene
specifically when Otto Hightower did
that because he's not sending his
daughter to [ __ ] the king to spite Damon
yeah like it's still your daughter yeah
of course right but when he did that
everything I thought about Damon flipped
yep and that is a genius filmmaking when
you take a character who looks like an
[ __ ] a cocky piece of [ __ ] who looks
like he's just he's going around town he
makes basically the the King's Guard he
makes it the the what is it called
she'll kill everybody watch he makes him
go kill everybody in like Hammurabi's
Code way like if you steal cut off your
arm like his dick and [ __ ] chop seduce
balls off because he was a rapist yeah
but like I love that you know like fire
but you make him look like this guy
who's being completely unreasonable
irrational and then in one moment he
calls out he goes all these people
around you are leeches and you're too
weak to recognize it um
kicks them out and then the next scene
one of the [ __ ] people you thought
was sweet the kind guy the nice guy the
reasonable guy sends his own daughter to
[ __ ] the king you're like oh [ __ ] is he
right yeah is this what leading meat and
I'm like this is brilliant yeah one
scene complete completely flips every
character yeah and what you thought of
every character
I'm like these guys are on it yeah yeah
these guys are [ __ ] on it bro did you
notice how he was hiding while they were
doing the little board meeting oh he was
right outside the door yeah and he
misses a lot of those meetings and I'm
wondering if he's actually there but no
one knows
one knows yeah and he tells his daughter
to be like hey Step Up for your dad yeah
mom and your brother go tell your dragon
to do that [ __ ] yeah
yeah I just thought it was [ __ ]
excellent
I thought and my wife had an interesting
thing to say about she's like I want to
see some progress I go what do you mean
she goes this is 100 or the opposite of
progress like she's like there's 174
years before we saw Game of Thrones why
are they wearing the same [ __ ] like
fashion changes like time to make people
evolve Etc and I tried to have an
argument against it it's a big ass for a
TV show
what's that it's just such a girl's
thing to pay attention to like it's some
old [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's like the medieval
times it was the same for a thousand
years or whatever like that's kind of
what I said that's what the time period
is based off of because the Medieval
Times yeah they can't go through and
study each sub like when they study
American history in 250 years or
whatever they're not going to be like oh
the 90s was this versus the 2000s was
this versus the 80s
what if the differences are so subtle
you don't even notice well that's what
I'm wondering I'm wondering if like
you know how actually now this is a much
larger discussion like if progress is
happening at an exponential rate now
like could you even have a show which
was called look at the 90s or you know
VH1's what's up with the 90s whatever
that show was like now you got to be
like what's up with 2020 yeah because
2021 is yeah complete different yeah
Tick Tock comes around and changes
everything yeah yeah but then maybe if
you look if you like zoom out and you
look at this time period and then like
if you look at this time of year 50
years from now maybe the decade will
kind of look similar yeah or 500 years
from now it's you're just going to have
a macroscopic view of like oh they wore
jeans and t-shirts different Baggins
different whatever they had social media
t-shirts yeah yeah yeah yeah okay the
same fashion essentially all right Fair
no sometimes you have a rip in the jeans
sometimes the shoe is it's shoes yeah
and jeans and a t-shirt all right so
other thoughts other thoughts anything
else that was interesting you thought
um I thought the CGI was way better than
Game of Thrones I've heard mixed reviews
on the CGI it's like the past the last
two seasons of Game of Thrones it like
you can see the dragon kind of look a
little like cartoonish at times like
this [ __ ] look legit you know one thing
I thought that was really smart what
they did is
uh there was
far away shots in the clouds with CGI so
one thing they used to do in movies to
like uh make it easier to blow things up
is just include fire just make you make
all scenes like super dark or dark I
noticed that with stranger things
stranger things is shot incredibly dark
so that way all that CGI [ __ ] is like
you don't got to put that much effort
into exactly the audio that does it for
you exactly and I think that with this
the budget's obviously going to be less
than Game of Thrones at least in the
beginning because they don't know how
successful it's going to be right season
six you could do a 10 million dollar 30
second scene or whatever they did for
that fight remember the battle of the
bastards lose 10 million dollars for and
at one episode or something crazy but I
think it's smart to at least in the
beginning scene when she's flying on the
dragon put that money in it like get us
but but there she's far away she's tiny
and there's cloud cover everywhere
so you don't really see the details of
the Dragon yeah but I mean like when he
was like walking up to the dragon and
like touching it and then had his girl
like touch it too and [ __ ] like that you
remember
um the blonde hair blonde hair Damon and
Missouri at the end
they're about to be banished and so that
he brings her they walk up to the dragon
and he's just like filling a dragon like
that [ __ ] just looks so real to me I
don't know but was it just the neck yeah
yeah but it but I I mean yeah you don't
even need CGI you literally just make a
neck and then just shoot the neck true
yeah can I ask you a question yeah I've
noticed anytime I look at CGI it looks
real when I see it and then in five ten
years everything progresses so fast I go
back and look at it I'm like this looked
terrible ah yeah like Jurassic Park they
look like most realistic thing ever [ __ ]
what is that this is a long cult huh
what's that law called uh the technology
is that a law
go miles there's a law that technology
advances two times faster every oh yeah
every single year so CGI from two years
ago looks incredibly different than what
you're used to yeah you re-watch like
the first Toy Story and you were like
that's the coolest [ __ ] in the world and
then you re-watch it you're like that
story again that [ __ ] look fire
the new Jurassic Park looks like trash
oh all the new Jurassic worlds are awful
I mean they're bad movies no but I mean
the CGI in it like you can tell they did
not think about Jurassic Park right when
do you see the T-Rex
rain dark rain night dark barely seeing
it with this this is a stranger things
thing you were saying yeah but this
latest one is like it's dinosaurs all
throughout the [ __ ] it's not like the
other ones where it's just like ah it's
a whole build up build a buildup and
then you see dinosaurs dinosaurs [ __ ]
up and actually looks super cheap it's
like the Jaws [ __ ] we like not seeing it
yeah you know why Stephen King did that
or Steven Spielberg did that no well he
went to a screening and he saw like how
fake the shark looked he was like this
looks so [ __ ] bad oh my God this is
gonna ruin the entire movie and that's
when he was like let's just have the fin
and the whole thing is a suspense of oh
wait I I thought they didn't film it yet
I thought it was they he looked at what
it could look like and then he was like
nah let's just not include it Oh I
thought he went to a screening maybe I'm
oh wow I thought he went to screening
and he was like this sucks I mean I
thought the screening was in Dallas and
that's how I heard it I could be getting
stories conflated Oh I thought it was
like he looked at what the shark would
look like and it was just it was thick
but maybe you're right but yeah great
choice yeah don't show it to us let it
be scary but we don't see it it's a
Jurassic Park the water shaking boom
you're like oh [ __ ] you see the Sheep
get eaten it goes into the woods and the
Sheep comes back and that's it yeah and
you could do that with the dragons like
I don't think you need to show us the
dragons that much in this like it's cool
that we see it that we know they're
there but once we know they're there man
you gotta seeing that much